"Eternals" is one of Marvel
Studios' most ambitious films.
It's an origin story for
almost a dozen characters,
and introduces a ton of intergalactic lore. With
so much setup, it's no surprise there are some
things left unanswered. These are the biggest
questions we have at the end of "Eternals."
The movie's climax sees the Eternals joining
powers and stopping the Celestial Tiamut
from destroying the Earth. After
some infighting and trepidation,
they all work together and petrify him
just as he's emerging from the sea.
It's a happy ending for humanity
-- not so much for the Eternals,
who now have to answer for sabotaging their
own mission, but certainly for humanity. Right?
Well, happy, yes. An ending? Not so much.
When the Eternals discussed their plan,
it was clear that they were only planning on
freezing the Celestial. It doesn't seem like
that plan changed, and the fact that his body
is still undamaged certainly implies he could
still be alive. Will the Eternals be there when
he breaks free? Will they find a way to extract
him without severely damaging the planet?
Time will hopefully tell -- especially if
humanity isn't deemed worthy enough once
Arishem examines the Eternals' memories.
Even if he's dead, though, there's still a
frozen Celestial emerging from the planet's core.
If nothing else, that's going to ruin more
than a few days somewhere in the world.
Dane Whitman only has a handful
of scenes in "Eternals," a small
surprise given that he's portrayed by
an actor as prominent as Kit Harington.
Even so, his scenes are of great
narrative and emotional importance.
In his final scene before the credits,
Dane starts telling Sersi that his family
history was more complicated than he
thought -- only to be so rudely interrupted
by Arishem literally stealing his girl.
The post-credits scene, however, teases
Dane's future. We see him approach a sword,
only to be asked by an unseen
voice if he wants to do that.
Comics fans will at least partly see where this
is going: Dane Whitman is the Black Knight,
a superhero who wields a powerful and mystical
sword. He's often portrayed as a descendant of
the original Black Knight, who appeared
in various adventure comics from Marvel
pre-Stan Lee. He's also the nephew of another,
villainous Black Knight -- and if the movies stay
true to the comics, that's likely the uncle with
whom Sersi said Dane had a strained relationship.
"Introducing the Eternals,"
"You hear that, Sprite? Family reunion."
"It's about time."
Ikaris is among the most thoroughly developed
members of the Eternals, and in the ensemble,
he's arguably one of the two or three
main characters. Partly because of this,
his future is pregnant with more
possibilities than anyone else on the team.
"Who do you think's gonna lead the Avengers?"
"I could lead them."
Originally hellbent on releasing the
latent Celestial from earth's crust,
his love of Sersi wins out
and he rethinks his mission.
When we last see him, he's flying
far away from Earth, into a star.
The obvious question is: what next? We didn't see
him when Arishem came back to Earth, and we didn't
see him on the ship in the post-credits scene.
He's almost certainly still out there, but where?
The two most likely possibilities are that
he informed Arishem himself of what happened,
likely seeking some kind of atonement, or that
he went into hiding from Arishem entirely.
Either way, we'll almost certainly see
him again and find out what happens next.
Early in the movie, Dane asks Sersi the question
we've all had since "Eternals" was announced: why
did they stay out of various human conflicts, up
to and including the one with Thanos? The answer:
the Eternals were explicitly instructed not
to get involved with any human affairs that
didn't involve the Deviants. Okay, fair
enough. That raises another question:
what about all that other
interfering they definitely did?
As an example, we see the Eternals protect
the residents of Babylon from the Deviants,
and it can be inferred that the Walls of Babylon
were meant to protect humans from Deviants.
But the Eternals were far more than mere
protection for the Babylonians -- they
were the most important and influential
beings there. They provided leadership,
guidance, and entertainment for the
comparatively primitive culture.
We do eventually find out that the
Eternals fight off the Deviants entirely so
their planet will develop the requisite amount
of intelligent life to incubate a Celestial.
This explains some of it, like how
Phastos developed farming equipment.
But Phastos didn't know about the true
purpose of the mission until much later.
If nothing else, surely they would have
realized over the course of centuries that
finite resources often lead
to conflict. Either way,
they sure interfered a lot for people
who weren't supposed to interfere.
Sersi's exact powers are a bit nebulous, but
one thing that's clear is that she's able to
manipulate and transform inanimate matter. This
mostly takes the form of changing something's
density or turning one form of matter
into another. Halfway through the movie,
she surprises herself with a new power: she
somehow turns a Deviant into a tree. This is
a major turning point in the movie, one that sets
up the climactic attempt to freeze the Celestial.
It's also never explained how she got that power.
At one point, she's asked point blank when it
happened. She responds that she doesn't know,
in a tone that shows she's
clearly baffled herself.
At no point in the film's runtime is it ever
explained exactly how she developed this power
or how long she's had it. It's possible
that becoming the leader of the Eternals
after Ajak's death contributed to
it, but that's never mentioned nor
explored. The power is plot critical, but the
reason she has that power remains a mystery.
Much to the chagrin of many moviegoers and
Marvel's PR department, the "Eternals" post
credits scene was leaked by a few
members of the west coast press:
Harry Styles has joined the MCU as Eros,
Thanos' handsome and charismatic brother.
Marvel tried very hard to hide this, going
so far as to cut both post credits scenes and
the credits themselves from screenings
outside of the Los Angeles premiere.
Eros, also known as Starfox, is far
less brutal than his brother in the
comics. That's not to say he's a good guy,
he's just not a universe-conquering titan,
and can alternate between hero or
villain depending on the story.
Eros' main power, besides the requisite
ability to shoot various beams, is that
of emotional manipulation: he can form psychic
connections with people and change how they feel.
There are several questions here, but
they all amount to the same thing:
what's he going to do in the MCU? Will he be the
next big villain? Will the upcoming "She-Hulk" on
Disney+ adapt the storyline in which he goes
on trial for manipulating women's feelings?
Perhaps most importantly, will
he sing? Please let him sing.
For half of "Eternals," we're led
to believe that the Deviants are an
evil alien force that indiscriminately
attacks life on various planets.
We're given no reason to doubt that and see the
Eternals -- who were supposedly created by the
Celestials to stop the Deviants -- fight them
off over the course of countless generations.
Then, about halfway into the movie, we're
thrown a curveball: the Celestials created
the Deviants first, as a way to control
environments with no natural apex predators.
They only became bloodthirsty after a flaw in
their design saw them evolve out of control.
At least one Deviant learns to talk,
and confirms this story to the Eternals. But
that raises the question: what was the flaw?
This is admittedly getting into the weeds a bit,
but "Eternals" is a movie packed to the gills
with detailed lore. Will we ever learn about
the Deviants' true design, or what went wrong?
Are the Deviants themselves aware of this flaw?
Can it be corrected? Given that we haven't seen
the last of the Deviants on Earth and have
barely seen them on any other planets at all,
we might find out one day. Or it'll never
be brought up again. Place your bets.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.